In order to create a circle similar to the circle that
represented China in the gapminder visualization,
we'll first need to figure out a way to map data values to pixels.
As I just mentioned, d3's scale module allows us to map from data values
to pixel values, or rather, from any arbitrary domain to any arbitrary range.
As you can see here in the auto complete that Chrome provides for us,
there's a linear scale, a log scale, ordinal, power, and so forth.
For the y axis, we'll be using a linear scale.
And with this scale, we'll be mapping a domain from 15 to 90 into a range
corresponding to the height of our SVG element, in this case 150 pixels.
One quirk I just mentioned is that since SVG's coordinate space actually has
zero values for y near the top and as you go down on the page the y
value increases, we actually want to flip the bounds for the range.
Such that they properly get mapped.
What this says here is create a scale that's linear,
maps to the domain 15 to 90, and to the range 150 and zero.
So in our case, the greatest domain value maps to the highest pixel value,
in this case zero being closest to the top of the browser window.
As you can see here, what's returned is actually a function.
And as I previously mentioned,
a scale can be thought of as a functional mapping from a domain to a range.
And that's exactly what d3 returns to us.
A function that, if given an x value, maps to a range appropriately, and
returns the value it's been mapped into.
Let us store the scale this time in a variable y,
corresponding to the scale of the y axis.
Since D3's API is very general and adaptable I'm simply going to
reuse the functions I just called but this time to create an x scale.